leute ich wurde gestern ernsthaft
zweimal in der stadt von irgendwelchen
wildfremden personen gruppen alle
quatsch auf welcher seite ich denn stehe
meine ganze instagram direct message
seit es voll damit
wegen so was und ich denke mir sowas
geht man hat deswegen gibt es dieses
video das ist allerdings längst nicht
der hauptgrund dass kommt gleich alles
ich hoffe youtube ist dann von dieser
scheiße befreit irgendwann den nächsten
tagen wirklich liegt mir sehr am herzen
und ich habe dazu hat auch ein bisschen
was zu sagen ich finde es voller sie ist
es einfach übels asozial viel spaß jetzt
ach so was ich vielleicht noch sagen
soll ich habe es wirklich gestern um
halb vier nachts aufgenommen deswegen
ist es richtig dunkel im video achtet
aber hauptsächlich auf die audiospur das
ist das wichtigste was ich zu sagen habe
ich hoffe das kommt gut rüber und ich
kann meine meinung so wie ich sie gerne
vertreten würde
gut sagen und ist natürlich ein bisschen
kindergarten so aber wie gesagt dieses
eine video danach will ich gar nichts
mehr davon hören bitte leute keinen bock
mehr darauf und jetzt viel spaß hieß
hey leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen
beim ein video ja ich bin gerade aus
köln wieder gekommen wir haben schon
gelogen 3 wurde also ich glaub ja schon
später moment muss erst mal kurz
abschenken drei b-2 heftig alter ich
wollte eigentlich gar kein video mehr
machen bzw
ich war ganz einfach auf youtube
unterwegs und hab halt diese ganze
scheiße mitbekommen oder was weiß ich
ich weiß ja schon länger von jetzt an
einem fahrrad her ist das interessiert
mich jetzt aber das war so eine omi die
zeit vom auszeit und diese uhrzeit um 3
uhr naja wir kommen zurück zum thema ich
weiß ja wie mich seht es mir aber auch
scheißegal
auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt einfach
gedacht komm du gehst noch raus ich geh
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen bis da
hinten und dann wieder zurück und
versuche ich alles ein bisschen zu
erklären was mir so gerade dazu einfällt
klar als erstes kann ich sagen das ist
vielleicht unnötig von mir dass ich mir
jetzt auch nicht einmische ich wollte
mich auch wirklich nicht einmischen weil
ich hab gesagt komm macht euer ding da
ist mir scheißegal
so habe ich schon immer gedacht weil ich
weiß schon länger dass die beiden sich
nicht mehr verstehen und so weiter
allerdings ich mach das video aus der
hauptgrund ist sag ich mal
ich möchte ein bisschen in schutz nehmen
weil er mir grad schon ziemlich leid tut
bzw
ihr könnt euch einfach meine meinung
anhören dass wird das einzige videos
seien von mir was sie was ihr dazu
bekommen werde
das wird auch mega schwer sich zu
konzentrieren weil ich auch müde bin
aber ich will das jetzt auf jeden fall
noch abdrehen also danach wird nichts
kommen egal was für die reaktion darauf
folgt ob der oder der sich darauf noch
meldet das ist das einzige alles was ich
dazu sagen kann sage ich jetzt im video
mehr werde ich nicht sagen
es sind auch viele sachen die sind viel
zu privat die werde ich auf egal ob es
jetzt für herz schlechtes oder für
miguel auf keinen fall mit reinziehen
sohn und ich fange jetzt mal ganz von
vorne an und zwar hat schon miguel
hatten ja damals irgendwann kontakte da
kann also ich keine heirat schon lange
mega lange seit 56 jahren oder so und
auch ziemlich gut vor allem letzter zeit
zu youtube hat da sag ich mal durch
youtube haben besser kennengelernt
ihr macht glaube ich schon vor vier
jahren also ins herz ist youtube video
zusammen gedreht
auf jeden fall hat er irgendwie mit
miguel kontakt gab und ich habe auch
videos von den beiden zusammen gesehen
fand ich cool und irgendwann habe ich
dann miguel auch mal kennengelernt von
einem guten kollegen von mir auf der
house party war dann irgendwie plötzlich
miguel keine ahnung warum der wahrheit
mit mirko und ich werde auch mit emi und
noch ein paar anderen wir haben uns noch
wirklich sofort mega gut verstanden so
bei uns und haben nun auch den rest des
abends so zusammen verbracht mich als
mega gefreut die kennengelernt zu haben
weil ich wusste ja die wohn halt hier in
der nähe und ist ja megacool die beiden
hatten eigentlich vor einem abend bei
dem cousin von harwich zu übernachten
weil die mich da noch gar nicht kann
also wir uns erst auf der party
kennengelernt
der war dann allerdings leicht
verhindert sich mal und dann habe ich so
gesagt oder halt angeboten ihr könnt
auch bei mir kennen kein thema und das
haben wir dann auch irgendwie gemacht
wir waren um 7 und 10 oder so
darauf hat gefolgt dass wir dann halt
alle zusammen auch mal gedreht haben ich
war ja auch mal bei miguel hat wirklich
mega bock gemacht und mich hat es
wirklich sehr gefreut hat die so kennen
zu lernen weil weiß sie dass sein immer
cool so andrea oder leute wegen youtube
kennenzulernen
und wenn man es wirklich auch richtig
gut verstanden so wir haben nicht viel
miteinander gemacht ich mal aber wir
haben uns gut verstanden so bleibe aber
irgendwie hat mir dann nicht mehr so
viel kontakt und dann kam halt auch so
raus irgendwie heraus und du ihr müsst
euch nicht mehr keine ahnung was da
passiert ist auf jeden fall hat er nicht
viel zugesagt er hat nur so gesagt ja
wir mögen uns gerade nicht blablabla das
wird jetzt allerdings kein beef oder so
also er wird nicht öffentlich machen das
einzige was er so zu mir gesagt hat war
dass er halt sprachnachrichten hat von
miguel mit denen er ihn so halt hoch
nehmen könnte sag ich mal und mehr
wusste ich davon auch nicht wusste nicht
was es versprach leichenwagen ich wusste
nur dass gegen seine freundin da war das
halt so hingenommen
und dann waren irgendwann letztens die
video dazed ich hab halt mit miguel sag
ich mal so einen monat hatten wir halt
kaum kontakt ich habe ihn zweimal
geschrieben darauf kam keine antwort ich
habe mir nichts dabei gedacht weil ich
so dachte jo weiß nicht vielleicht
dieser beschäftigt fand ich natürlich
schade und auch irgendwie ein bisschen
weiß ich nicht warum man da nicht
antwortet so was ihr auch übels schade
finde das kann ich auch ganz offen sagen
so ebene und ich wir wussten dass ja
dass ihr euch nicht mit also du warst
auf jeden fall ja öfter hier irgendwie
was mit weiteren kollegen von
herausgestellt ich auch ganz gut kenne
und das hat sich dann halt hier so
irgendwie rum gesprochen auch so freunde
die eigentlich gar nichts mit ihr zu tun
hatten haben so gesagt jo oder auch
durch deine videos miguel ist doch voll
abgehoben
blablabla wollte abgehoben spaß so von
wegen weiß das kann man so sagen sag ich
mal und ihm und ich habe wirklich immer
gesagt so jo thema das halt so
in videos ist manchmal ein bisschen
anders in videos das sollen unterhaltung
sein blabla so und dann waren ja die
video days
und da habe ich dann halt gesehen so und
hab halt so gesagt ja was geht und dann
kamst du irgendwie so ich trinke aus
irgendwie ist angesagt sei leise und bis
weg du hast mich halt irgendwie so
ignoriert was ich nicht verstanden habe
ich hab dann irgendwie so hinter meinem
rücken und hinter dem rücken bzw andere
leute haben mir das erzählt dass du
irgendwie kein bock mehr auf mich hasst
weil ich den gleichen bzw mit der
gleichen klamotten marke kooperiere wie
du auch der mich halt angeschrieben habe
ich gesagt ja gerne weil ich die marke
auch feiere meinen du ruhig sagen können
ja lass das bitter oder so jetzt hier
mal kurz anrufen können aber blockieren
auf instagram das war dann halt so ein
bisschen fragwürdig für mich so wurde
bei mir dann auch ein bisschen unten
durch fast sage ich mal weil das ergibt
für mich keinen sinn ich mein mann kann
im anderen noch mal kennen sagt ja auch
so gern doch oder so keine ahnung ist
auch egal das war jetzt halt nur die
sache die ich an dich mal kurz loswerden
wollte ich meine gut gibt schlimmeres
allerdings habe ich dann halt so diesen
disstrack gesehen und das war dann so
für mich so dieses sache so ich dachte
alter wieso ich meine ich gebe es offen
zu der beef zwischen herz schon mir war
übrigens asozial und sowas sollte man
auf keinen fall machen also ein fake
beef aber einen realen beef so auch
nicht so erst recht nicht so pfiffig das
ein was ich vergessen habe gestern
sozusagen also ich weiß noch ganz genau
ich saß mit derartigen wieso um 2 uhr
noch nirgends im restaurant wir haben
das alles durchgesprochen
ja der biva fake das hast du richtig
analysiert aber ich habe noch so gehört
in diesem video du hast gesagt du
wolltest auf keinen fall dabei sein weil
du deine community nicht anlügen
wolltest und ich weiß ganz genau ich
kannte dich da noch nicht aber herr rath
hat mit den noch telefoniert oder
geschrieben und du hast eindeutig gesagt
du willst auch auf jeden fall dabei sein
und ich noch einmischen ich habe jetzt
auch keinen dummen beweis zu eine
sprachnachricht oder ein screenshot den
ich jetzt ein werden können sowie das ja
andauernd gemacht habe um irgendwie den
anderen wieder hoch zu nehmen aber was
ich auf jeden fall beruhigt ist dass du
das jetzt siehst du weißt ganz genau
du wärst gern dabei gewesen
beziehungsweise wolltest dabei seien
hätten wir das nicht sofort aufgelöst
weil es dumm von uns war und wir viel
geld dafür bekommen haben da hast du
recht mehr dazu wollte was ich jetzt gut
finde du hast in einem neuen video
gesagt soja beleidigt den ich oder
beleidigt den ich als sohn oder sonst
was
das ist dann leichter widerspruch zu dem
distrikt deh nicht ich weiß ich mich hat
das so voll wütend gemacht weil du weißt
selber ein paar sachen daraus stimmen
das gebe ich offen und ehrlich zu aber
viele sachen sind auch gelogen
und sowas mit freundin fremdgehen in die
öffentlichkeit ziehen das finde ich hart
das ist richtig hart das sollte man auf
keinen fall machen egal was die andere
person ein getan hat so das war dann für
mich halt so ein grund wo ich dachte
alter den ernst so was so was gehört
sich nicht und dann war das image von
harwich also wie gesagt ich mache dieses
video
der hauptgrund ist weil ich hätte
einfach in schutz nehmen möchte weil ich
nicht will dass die karriere von harwich
die er sich wirklich schon mit vielen
mir aufgebaut hat ja ja auch durch mich
sage ich mal
ich habe ja dazu nochmal angestiftet so
mit youtube anzufangen und so weiter hab
auch damals mit ihm viele videos gemacht
wir drehen ja heutzutage immer noch
viele videos aber damals halt auf und
mich freut's mega das herab damit so
erfolgreich ist dass wir noch jemanden
habe mit dem ich mich sehr gut verstehe
und wir haben halt auch das gleiche
hobby können dass beide erfolgreich
beziehungsweise einigermaßen erfolgreich
durchführen und ich will nicht das herz
durch sonne scheint irgendwie zerstört
wird beziehungsweise ein image zerstört
wird und irgendwie muss ihr herz schon
darauf reagieren und hat dann so dieses
lange aufklärungs video gemacht 30
minuten was ich mir dann auch angeguckt
habe irgendwie halt so oberflächlich sag
ich mal
und dann habe ich wirklich zum aller
ersten mal dieses sprachnachrichten
gesehen die ihr da geschickt habe über
seine freundin so und da dachte ich
wirklich so komplett fass was ist das
warum wie kann man so sein so weiß es
wie kann man das ist doch keine
menschlichkeit mehr das ist selbst wenn
noch so sollten noch so eine scheiße
gemacht hätte dann beleidigt hätte so
aber zieht doch nicht seine freundin mit
rein stellt euch mal vor seine freunde
hat es ja sicherlich alles gesehen wie
fühlte sich denn wie fühlt man sich als
mensch wenn man sowas über sich hört
über sich selber ich kann euch einmal
kurz die stelle ein wenn die ich meine
das war für mich jetzt vor allem der
ausschlag gebe hier noch mal ein video
zu machen und herab einen schutz zu
nehmen
ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen wer da
wie oder wo oder was irgendwie
sprachnachrichten verändert hat oder
anders dargestellt hat das war
sicherlich auf beiden seiten zum teil
der fall so aber das war wirklich der
haupt ausschlaggebende grund ich meine
du hast auch angefangen mit dem bmi geld
warum ich jetzt dieses video mache auf
jeden fall um da jetzt noch mal
zurückzukommen auf diese
sprachnachrichten oder videos die er da
über harrys freundin gemacht habe es ist
für mich scheiß egal ob zu dem zeitpunkt
mit ihr zusammen war
obwohl nicht mit ihr zusammen war mit
wem auch immer werder zusammenbau oder
wer mit wem fremdgegangen ist solche
sprache reden kann man einfach nicht
senden das ist einfach komplett
respektlos finde ich es ist selbst aus
spaß weil es spaß gewesen ist ein
insider oder sonst was macht man nicht
ich kann ich kann ganz klar bestätigen
das herz auf diese sprachnachrichten
definitiv geschrieben hat
bitte hört auf damit und damit habt ihr
nicht aufgehört das habe ich wirklich
gesehen auf dem handy und auf dem handy
kann man nichts felgen live in whatsapp
oder und das ist für mich der punkt
warum wir gerade für mich von unten
durch seit ich habe eigentlich gar
nichts gegen euch ich fand's mega schade
dass das du mich blockiert hass und mir
jetzt nicht antwortest du also ich hatte
eine nummer gerade auch nicht mehr ich
hab sie gelöscht okay ich habe keine
ahnung ob meine argumentation hat so
rüberkommt wie es gerne hätte aber ich
hoffe es auf jeden fall also wir haben
einmal diese beiden punkte meiner
meinung nach ich muss einfach nur ins
bett
auf jeden fall ich möchte einmal gern
harwich in schutz nehmen weil viele
sachen einfach nicht so stimmen und er
das bloß gestellt wurde in diesem
distrikt ich mal und auf der anderen
seite fand ich diese sprach ihn wirklich
übels cars tiefgründig unter diesem
asphalt hier heftig so das hat mich
richtig ich habe mich richtig geschämt
dafür wie man so die man seine
sprachlich senden kann klar ist kann es
spaß gewesen sein aber selbst aus
größten spaß
schickt man keine sprache nicht so über
die freundin bzw ex-freundin von einem
ehemaligen freund beziehungsweise einem
immer noch bestehenden freund soll ich
mal wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin dass geht
es vor allem an miguel mit dem rest habe
ich eigentlich überhaupt kein problem
zurzeit mit ihr muss ich nicht unbedingt
befreundet sein ist kein problem ich
stehe auf jeden fall der heirat stehen
kann ich schon lange ich würde mich da
jetzt ganz gerne
auf den heimweg machen hier ist jetzt
noch grad ganz gutes sich was zum
abschluss noch sagen wollte respekt ist
meiner meinung nach richtig wichtig im
leben egal ob ein mensch eine million
euro hat egal ob ein mensch gar nichts
hat egal ob events 50 abonnenten hat
oder 1 million abonnenten im endeffekt
ist jeder menschen mensch und jeder
mensch sollte respekt gegenüber gezeigt
werden und diesen respekt lernen die
meisten kinder schon mit sechs jahren
und manche leute denken vielleicht wenn
unter dem eigenen youtube video steht
400.000 aufrufe kann man respekt wieder
verwerfen sage ich mal dass es nicht der
fall meiner meinung nach deswegen habe
respekt vor jedem deswegen meine
abschießen wollte jetzt endlich miguel
bild dir bitte nix auf dreieinhalb
darauf ein ist schön freut mich sehr für
dich
allerdings ist respekt deutlich
wichtiger als hype und mehr wollte ich
nicht sagen an alle
wie gesagt das ist die einzige messe
schule im ganzen von mir und ich würde
sehr freuen wenn ihr alles super
hinterfragt und vielleicht einfach nur
auf youtube unterhaltung sehen wollt und
nicht irgendwelche biebs wale dann
hinterher rennen war im endeffekt nur
die hälfte von stimmen und zwar youtuber
komplett privat zerstört werden weil sie
meinen gegenseitig irgendwelche privaten
dinge zu veröffentlichen und da ist für
mich also mehr geld angefangen
du hast von übertrieben einer meinung
nach das hat der rat auf keinen fall
verdient und mehr will ich dazu jetzt
auch nicht sagen
vor allem auch nicht heraus freundin das
tut mir auch mega light und haut rein
wir sehen uns morgen beim ein video
keystone was zum abschluss noch sagen
heute bitte haltet wirklich jedes meiner
anderen videos daraus diskutiert hier
drunter liegt dieses video display
dieses video ist mir vollkommen egal
meine anderen videos stehen für
unterhaltung und da ist für bi keinen
platz meiner meinung nach
deswegen muss ist schlafen hat schöne
nacht
alicia keys